[Musique]
en fait là vous êtes sur le qe2 du port
de rimouski et celle endroit où
débarquent principalement les crabiers
il y avait aussi des pêcheurs de
brouille à qui ça qui venaient en ce
moment c'est la pleine saison du crap
monsieur bret et professeur à l'institut
des sciences de la mer de rimouski est
aussi certificateur pour le msc
le marine stewardship council un
organisme qui s'assure que la pêche est
fait de façon responsable et durable
alors une paix durable c'est un certain
nombre de principes qui sont associés à
sa d'abord c'est le respect de la
ressource
donc en fait péché pour ne pas épuiser
ne pas utiliser la ressource
ça c'est la première la laddh ensuite
c'est le péché que ce qui est nécessaire
s'ajoute le respect de l'environnement
des écosystèmes et des collectivités qui
dépendent de la ressource
l'an passé les méthodes de pêche des
crabiers du sud du golfe du saint
laurent ont nui aux baleines noires et
causé la mort de certaines d'entre elles
le crabe de cette région ne peut donc
plus être certifiée durable
en fait le problème c'est les cordes
fait les aurains qui relie le cas lié à
une bouée en surface donc vous avez 600
mètres de profondeur vous avez 150 200
mètres de câble qui part du fond vers la
bouée et donc les baleines se prennent
dans les câbles donc elles peuvent
s'étouffer seul et se noyer en étant
pris dans les câbles
donc là le msc a demandé à ce qu'ils les
mesures qu'ils soient mises en place et
en attendant que soient mises en place
et que l'on vérifie qu'elle soit
efficace
la certification fsc
des certifications et des logos pour
s'assurer que la pêche est durable il y
en a de toutes les sortes sur les
produits de la pêche et de l'aquaculture
il peut être difficile de s'y retrouver
et surtout de siffler un des gros
problème présentement dans le domaine
c'est que le terme pêche durable n'est
pas réglementé comme les consommateurs
sont vraiment intéressés par la pêche
durable puis à faire des bons choix bien
évidemment l'industrie s'est mise a
explosé dans ce domaine là et on s'est
mis à développer près de certification
et oui je mets des guillemets comme ça
parce que j'ai plein de certification
avec lesquels on n'est pas trop certains
ou du moins son poteau aussi rigoureuse
les unes que les autres
j'ai même vu par expérience des
compagnies qui mettait des fologo
donc on a l'impression que le groupe est
durable parce que c'est comme étant un
petit poisson bleu dans un fond blanc
c'est du poisson quai de pêche durable
mais en réalité c'est comme une
décoration sur l'emballage
sans compter toutes les certifications
qui sont en fait des guides de
consommation des recommandations qui
sont donnés par exemple par greenpeace
pour toute autre organisation à la
limite une association un groupe un
aquarium peut dire peut décider de faire
sa propre liste effectivement il y en a
beaucoup
alors ici c'est l'aquarium puis on est
en train de rentrer dans le grand tunnel
de l'océan l'aquarium du québec s'est
associé au programme aux chinoises afin
d'établir une liste
un guide des produits de pêche durable
on a des milliers d'espèces qui sont
passés de différentes façons qui
proviennent des quatre coins de la
planète
on a différentes mesures de gestion le
consommateur est perdu
puis trop souvent sur les emballages on
retrouve pas d'informations qu'on pose
des questions à nos serveurs notre
poissonnier peuvent pas vraiment nous
répondre alors aux chinoises auraient
vraiment éclairé tous à faciliter la
tâche du consommateur à faire des bons
choix quand il voit notre petit logo is
casse pas la tête
ici qui est en train de faire un choix
qui est durable qui respecte nos océans
[Musique]
dans cette poissonnerie on s'assure
d'afficher la traçabilité et le logo
chinoise dans la vitrine peut être
rassurant mais attention il suffit qu'un
seul produit soient issus de la pêche
durable pour pouvoir s'afficher ocean
wise cela ne certifie pas que tous les
produits sont de pêche durable les
certifications nous demande d'avoir au
moins un produit durable ou chinoise en
l'occurrence pour cette certification ne
demande d'avoir au moins un produit en
inventaire à la mer nous entonnons
environ 1 500 produits ne sont pas
toutes certifiées à ocean wise
mais on va on va laisser l'information
aux clients ils vont être capables de
juger si oui ou non ils veulent le
produit qui est durable pas c'est plus
qu'un outil de marketing pour n'aime pas
c'est que c'est vraiment on les amène
sur un cheminement d'amélioration
continue puis un jour le but c'est
qu'ils soient 100% aux chinoises le
crabe rimouski pour le vivant et on est
sur la côte nord on est à sept îles dans
le cuir donc cette année oui nous allons
vendre du craps et pas une saison que
nous pouvons se permettre de manquer les
consommateurs sont six yeux on en a
entendu parler
est-ce qu'ils vont arrêter de le mettre
sur l'assiette je ne pense pas on parle
du ton depuis des années et on continue
toujours à en vendre quand on sait que
93 millions de tonnes de poissons sont
capturées chaque année dans le monde
le consommateur a un rôle à jouer en
diversifiant les espèces qu'ils achètent
et en posant des questions
1 demandez à votre poissonnier
c'est lui qui est censé connaître ces
informations là et moi ce que je dis
souvent c'est si votre poissonnier n'est
pas capable de vous donner
d'informations sur votre poisson changer
poissonnier quand on n'a pas de
poissonnier à notre disposition on peut
toujours se tourner vers un poissonnier
virtuel comme avec l'application seafood
watch
ce qui nous recommande comme le goût en
majorité cm et ses îles
asc qui est le pendant pour
l'aquaculture on voit qu'il va
donc si le canada celui nantes
atlantique
notre esthétique note macro donc oui le
choix qui un bon choix le problème qu'on
a très souvent avec ces listes sexé
catégoriser par très très gros gros
ensemble donc il peut y avoir à
l'intérieur d'un ensemble des pêcheurs
qui font du qui font un travail propre
qui font qu'ils sont conscients mais ils
sont noyés dans une évaluation globale
acheter ou pas les produits de la mer
peut être une décision complexe quand on
connaît l'importance pour notre santé
mais aussi celle des océans
le dilemme pour moi qui est
nutritionniste est que j'encourage les
gens à manger du poisson mais en même
temps plus on en mange plus on doit
vider les océans pour est capable de
faire si on veut que les générations
futures aient assez de poisson à manger
mais faut qu'on fasse des choix qui soit
cohérente du moins qu'on fasse les bons
choix de poisson